kate middleton and prince william's trip
to scotland just
keeps getting cuter the duke and duchess
of cambridge have been on an official
tour of the country
and they've clearly been having a blast
during the trip
just yesterday kate even tried her hand
at djing much to williams dismay
[Music]
then on tuesday the duchess had the
sweetest interaction while greeting
local school
children
[Music]
while she's technically not a princess
kate nodded her head
yes because hey points for effort and on
top of this school visit william and
kate also pop by their shared alma mater
in scotland where they first
met university of saint andrews
the royal couple even hit the beach for
a round of land yachting
[Music]
but it was william that perhaps had the
best encounter
in their trip so far what can i get you
got the flake in there as well
on sunday he visited queens bay lodge a
nursing home in scotland
where the prince was called out for
flirting with some of the residents
i think this is very important for the
cambridges to reach out to a
a new demographic essentially a younger
audience they
realize the value of streaming they've
got a brilliant digital team behind them
we've seen more of them i think at home
relaxed
in their own time during the pandemic
through video conference calls and
videos that they've chosen to release
i think we'll see more of that